all right well it's currently airing
season seven arrow is set to wrap up
next season with season eight with a
shorter one only 10 episodes star
Stephen Amell on our Facebook live to
emotionally reveal the news is it's been
nearly seven years since we shot the
pilot of arrow and just a few minutes
ago on the well just outside the stage
where we actually shot most of the pilot
where I came my very first time coming
to the production office and collide and
where I met most of the crew a lot of
which were there today on earth on our
cameras test day and just our sort of
first day of school before we began
production I just let everyone know that
after a ten episode running after a ten
episode run it in season eight arrow
will be concluding even though I've
known that this is coming it is still a
very emotional time because I have
been on the show and what can only be
described as a fundamentally
transformational nearly decade-long run
in my life to to start it as a as an
actor who doesn't have a lot of
experience who was you know sort of
dating someone to now a large part of
this decision being because I'm now a
father and a husband and a lot of my
life and interests now don't really
reside in Vancouver anymore and thinking
that that's the best thing for me
personally and professionally to say
that it has been a real sea change over
the past seven plus years would be a
vast understatement
so was he leaving or did they cancel the
show right so right at the beginning of
this video he seemed almost shocked and
emotional but he goes on to say that he
actually approached the producers and
said I think I'm gonna be done with this
character and he has a child now he as
he was saying that part it made it seem
like I walked outside and they told me I
was fired shoot the show in Vancouver
yeah his wife and daughter live in Los
Angeles so he's seeing it like so he's
gonna have he's been going back and
forth this whole time so he's just at
the point it's time to get back to my
kids this character and the story line
surrounding Oliver Queen really has come
to an end I mean this show if you think
about it first launched in 2012 on the
CW is a surprise hit for the CW and then
how many other shows have been a part of
the shared universes arrow errs flush
yeah
legends of tomorrow so he's kind of left
like this great you know continue with
this legacy kind of deal there's way
more shows coming up we've seen it
before well I mean I don't know how well
it does in ratings but shows have moved
because stars refused to you know it's
shooting location yeah no it's true
at least isn't very sad to know that
arrow ascending embarrasses I love
Stephen Amell I think if the show has to
come to an end
Attie says he didn't have an eight-year
contract so if you're paying attention
to that as well as his bond with his
daughter you'd see the writing on the
wall but also to like I mean he talks
through the crew in that the idea that
like obviously television is a cyclical
thing like shows and but you have to
think yeah he feels some responsibility
that there's all this crew thinking out
basically going to be out of work
because I'm like I know Alan Pompeo is
kind of hinted that with Grey's Anatomy
that like that's
part of the element that she why she
keeps going cuz one the impact the show
has on the audience but also like all
these people are employed and basically
when I'm done with the show all these
people are gonna be a lot more people
are you deciding you know what I'm ready
to move on so I'm sure that sound with
Steven to that like he he knows people
are gonna be out of work say this about
grace and I've been watching I've seen
every episode of gray since day one
hey I am a massive fan I would stick
around for two seasons without gray on
it but they have said like Shonda Rhimes
is not I don't think the show folds if
she leaves like she thinks it does but
she's not what Shonda Rhimes has said
that it's done when I don't and as a fan
I'm telling you it doesn't have to be
done tried they try with their even
Stephen Amell went to the crater and
said like you maybe you can we do so
baby but like I don't really see the
shows cold but I've interviewed about
conventions before and this guy seems to
me he whatever he does to put like 200%
in like it's like he doesn't know how to
almost not to say you can't juggle both
but I think this has taken up so much of
his time from the working out from
eating from how many episodes per season
shooting away from his family I just get
the sense he's kind of just pushed as
far as he can also seven years is not
bad yeah eight season two television is
Paula says kids always come first time
flies yeah yeah
[Music]